whenever you think you're not good
enough or i'm not an
expert enough it's it's hindering you
from
pushing past a boundary that you've
never explored and it's scary but it's
so worth it
for yourself not for the person on the
other side which of course you'll give
value
and your love for whatever it is you
have but it's for you mostly
if you clicked on this video there's a
high likelihood
that you have not been posting videos
don't worry i'm not going to shame you
today we are going to go
all in when we talk about the beliefs
that we have
when it comes to why we're not posting
videos and we're going to be sitting
down with
jordan prez from the think media team
who just started her channel
and is now at a thousand subscribers it
wasn't easy
but we're gonna dive into the belief
systems self-doubt and imposter syndrome
on today's episode of the think media
podcast
if you're brand new to this podcast my
name is heather torres
and every single tuesday we post a brand
new podcast episode for you so if you
like content like this
make sure you subscribe wherever you
consume this type of content
now today's interview is probably one of
my favorites not because we're just
talking
about one of my favorite subjects which
is overcoming self-doubt
starting messy and pressing record but
because we're sitting down with
my friend jordan perez she's part of our
think media team here
she's also a working full-time
homeschool mom
of three kids and she is crushing her
youtube channel
she just got to a thousand subscribers
and she is being monetized now
and i cannot wait to talk about the
limiting beliefs
that she had and that i had when we got
started so
grab your journal grab your cup of
coffee and let's jump into today's
episode
[Music]
well i am excited about today's
interview because i'm sitting down with
jordan perez she's one of my good
friends and a think
media team member jordan welcome to the
think media podcast
thank you it's really exciting to be
here i am excited because
you have been creating on youtube for
about a year now
and you started your channel you're over
a thousand subscribers congratulations
and i wanted to talk about some of the
self-doubts
some of the myths that come around
starting a youtube channel it's not easy
to do that
and you and i actually just got done
doing some focus groups with
our video ranking academy members and we
were asking them questions about
how they got started what were some of
the fears that were holding them back
so i thought maybe you and i could
unpack that today um
so why don't you tell everyone uh how
you got started on
your own youtube channel uh so the way i
got started on this
youtube journey was of course i work on
a team where everybody does youtube
so it was encouraging but also extremely
scary to get started
and so with the encouragement of my team
my husband
and just a passion that i had i decided
to take the plunge
and get my channel started yeah and you
know here at think media we're actually
a team
of uh 13 full-time people and some of us
are front-facing like myself and sean
and omar
and nolan and some of us are behind the
scenes so
getting started and putting yourself out
on camera probably wasn't the first
choice or the first thing that you
wanted to do
no no that is my place behind the camera
is exactly where i want to be so doing
this
was a huge challenge for me now we
didn't force you to start a youtube
channel jordan
but we were definitely encouraging you
because you have a lot of skills and a
lot of talents
tell everyone kind of how you chose what
you chose you have an
amazing youtube channel all about
chakuteri boards why did you choose
that i chose chicory boards because
it was it was a list of ideas and
passions that i had
but what i really wanted to do was not
have anything forced because i know that
if it was forced i wouldn't be
all in on it and so it was just
being more self-aware every day of what
i was doing
what i was enjoying what sparked joy
in my heart and that crazy enough
is meat and cheese and serving it to
friends family eating it by myself
in my kitchen in between meetings that
is what i did
so i knew that hey i can do this and
when you have that spark of
i can do this that that's when i knew
just go for it just try
yeah and i would say that your cheese
boards and your meatboards
are to die for they're so good uh now
you know i
have told people here on the podcast
before i waited three years before i got
started on youtube i had a lot of
beliefs about myself
and uh really lack of self-confidence
and i'm not really the heather
i was i am today that i was back then
when i got started but
i've been doing this a while i've pumped
out hundreds of videos now so this is
more natural for me
but for you and for the the video
ranking academy members that we were
interviewing
there were a lot of self-doubt and
beliefs that we had
um about ourselves when it came to
getting started on videos and one of
those was i just i don't really know how
to do this right like we didn't grow up
you and i weren't the techy people in in
school like understanding how
smartphones and cameras and audio and
video and all that
that wasn't where where my passion was
and so getting started on youtube i
really had that like i don't know how to
do this
feeling i think that's it's funny you
say iphones because the reality is we
get an iphone
we don't open up the instruction manual
manual
we just literally open it up start it up
and just start playing around
and really that's exactly what i felt
like i was doing with youtube
is that sure i had the instructions sure
i had
heather and sean to guide me but at the
same time i knew i needed to just go in
do it for myself try test whatever it
looked like
and just be okay with going for it yeah
and i think one of those beliefs about
like well i just i don't know how
um man we have an entire online
university
at think media to help people learn how
to do it and i think
for me specifically you know omar and i
have had lots of conversations about
uh what ios means and what aperture
means
and there just always seems to be this
block of well i just don't know what
that is and honestly it really is just
the idea that i haven't prioritized
learning how to do those things and
learning those things because it didn't
feel important enough to me
right absolutely and i think that's what
i
loved about getting started making that
first video and realizing oh
okay wait a minute i actually do have to
learn exactly how to tag and title and
descriptions
and all of those things and so it's not
having this huge weight of pressure but
knowing
where to find your education from and
then pursuing it
one step at a time applying it each time
which is what sean always says
to just apply what you've learned and
just keep going yeah when i look at even
your videos you know you're you're over
20 videos in
probably over 30 by the time this
podcast comes out and
every video it's just getting one
percent better learning one new thing oh
you know if i angle the camera this way
oh if i
change the lighting this way that it
looks different and i think
one of the things that people struggle
with is that idea of being able to just
practice
in public and just being okay with it
not being
okay right it's it's very difficult to
practice in public
uh not only with just out in the world
of youtube but around your peers around
your family
it's very challenging to step foot into
those unknowns of what they might think
or say to you
but it's so worth it it's so worth
taking that step yeah and
really when we were talking to our uh to
our members
another one that came up was you know
who am i to be doing this i'm not an
expert in anything and
mind you i did not go to school for
teaching i did not go to school for
uh you know learning how to do youtube i
didn't go to school even to become a
homeschool mom you know for my
homeschool channel
but uh and you didn't did you go to
culinary school in jordan
just making sure but this idea of
i who am i to be doing this this idea
that we kind of
we really talk ourselves down for who
we are and the gifts and talents that we
have been gifted yeah it's
it's very much that imposter syndrome
and it's so real
because i think the same thing who am i
to tell you what cheese goes with
what meat like i it's just my taste
and they're not that elegant and
unfortunately
that can hold us back from actually just
sharing who we are so really i try to
think of
when i'm sharing these videos it's from
my perspective not from an expert's
perspective it's just
hey i love it you might like this try it
out and so
it's understanding that it's it's okay
to
test the waters and you can do this it's
okay to not be an expert at it
yeah i when i teach on stage about
imposter syndrome for me
i really teach people that you know we
think that we only know 10
and that someone's going to find out
that we don't know everything and
let me just tell you you you probably
don't know everything but neither does
anyone else and so the idea that
if you are deep into meat and cheeses
like jordan if you
are really into running or you're really
into gaming
you are probably already an expert in
some capacity
let me tell you when i go to the grocery
store which i don't even like to do
jordan so there's
number one where we i can't even connect
in that but number two
i wouldn't know if this cheddar goes
with this
meat but you're so deep in researching
it and knowing it that you're not an
imposter
you're just a friend on the journey
you're a leader in this space you're
just a guide one or two steps ahead and
so the idea of like who am i to be doing
this feels like a shrinking
and i want people to kind of like step
out and say no i'm here i want to be a
part of this community
i want to contribute in my own way and i
think that's something that you've done
so well is that you're not like anyone
else you're really just doing it
jordan's way
right and it's it's all that mindset and
belief system
and it's so true that feeling of
shrinking in
it's it's literally that feeling that
you just can't express
with words and so whenever you think
you're not good enough
or i'm not an expert enough it's it's
hindering you
from pushing past a boundary that you've
never explored and it's scary but it's
so worth it for yourself
not for the person on the other side
which of course you'll give value
and your love for whatever it is you
have but it's for you mostly
yeah i think uh the last one is really
i'm not ready that was a big theme you
know when we interviewed people
they'd taken the courses they had
watched the videos they had come to the
conferences
and yet they still hadn't started the
channel
and i think that holds so much in that
you know i'm not ready
really is this idea of what if this
fails what if i have to do this in front
of my friends and it doesn't work what
if
i you know what if i miss out on
opportunities or you know what it was
what if this fails and i just love to
encourage people and say
what if it's the opposite like what if
this succeeds
like what if your security like what if
your chakuteri channel jordan
literally becomes the next rachel ray we
don't know
but unless you take that step and you
just go for imperfection
and you just know that everything is
figureoutable you won't actually know
if this is going to be a thing yeah i
it's
very real for me to just remember when i
started
of not feeling ready and wanting to make
sure
my kitchen looked perfect my hair was
perfect that
um i had to pretend and put on this
facade and i just remember it blocking
me every time before i press record
so my first video that i have is
horrible
but that's because i let go of all those
ideas
i made peace with the fact that i'm not
gonna be happy with this
but i'm gonna do it anyway and so it's
it's finding peace within yourself to
then press record and release it
and then start all over yeah every day
new video yeah and it really is just
about starting messy right and i love
how you just touched on that it's like
you know yeah so your kitchen's not
perfect but guess what it looks like
90 of other people's kitchens you know
it's it's the idea that you know my
homeschool doesn't look perfect and
that's okay
because that's what most families look
like you know that the things we're
doing are like most families and so
i just want to encourage you um if
you're listening to the podcast right
now and you've not
started your channel today's the day my
friend it is time for you to step up
to go to think media if you need help on
how
you know to to set up the lighting or do
the camera but really don't even have
all that as the
the first part of it just make a video
just say how to do
something teach someone something get
the video camera in front of you because
you're going to need to start creating a
lot of content to start feeling natural
and
they're for this to feel more normal for
people so jordan
if people are interested in checking out
your channel you just got past a
thousand subscribers they want to see
what it's like to be an iphone creator
where can they go
they can go to amazinggrazeboards on
youtube and find me there and all my
amazing videos for chicutery yes and
this is actually a part of a three-part
series so
if you didn't check out our interview
over on think media
where jordan and i talk about getting to
your first 1000 subscribers make sure
you check out that video
and then if you have not seen the way
that jordan creates her videos we walked
through her setup how simple a setup can
be
and how easy it can be to get to that
1000 subscribers with just
using your iphone well i hope you
enjoyed that interview with myself and
jordan
and make sure you check out our channel
give her some love let her know you are
from
the podcast but i just wanted to
encourage you one more time that there
is no
better day to start than today so grab
your iphone
grab what you have and just get started
this journey on youtube
it will not happen overnight but it
won't happen unless
you get started so if you're feeling the
imposter syndrome or you don't know how
or why me you can do this if i can do
this
and jordan can do this you can do this
too and i want to say thank you so much
for
all of the listeners who tune in every
single week for this tuesday ritual that
we have here on the podcast thank you so
much for
liking and subscribing and for leaving
your reviews
over on apple today's uh review actually
comes
from ulti1308
ulti says youtube geniuses wow thank you
so much for that compliment
she says i love the think team's passion
knowledge
and i could name so many more things the
effort and value
they bring every week is incredible
thank you think team will ulti 1308
thank you for being a part of our think
crew i've been calling you guys that
lately because that's
what i think you are we are all in this
together we're a crew
on this journey together we're action
takers
and we are trying to create and make an
impact
in the world so thank you so much for
rating and reviewing
today's podcast and if you've not
checked out our free
master class that's probably your next
step after today's episode
you'll learn the three secrets to
youtube success and
how to create a high impact and a high
profit youtube channel
you can get all the details at
thinkmasterclass.com
thank you so much for being a part of
our community here and we'll catch you
in the next episode
[Music]
you